a woman couldn't even vote before we're
coming up on her first woman president
soon it's only gonna make her believe
stronger that she's gonna be the first
woman in the NBA it's funny cuz all the
girls look at her like oh she's only
nine ten years old she goes out there
and she makes a fool out of him you that
golfer she hit the jumper if you come up
owners you're gonna go by you she was a
girl playing against boys and she was
dominating it was just so natural so I
just let her fly Jada Newland and I was
point guard for the Danny Christian
schools varsity team ninth annual Donny
Christian is a private school we don't
have a governing body saying oh you have
to have these stipulations to play long
as you can perform and you know excel in
the parents of the child are okay with
it you know you can play we had a few
good girls we needed another ball
handler so I was like let's use Jayden
you know let's see what she can do
well you had a couple people that were
for it and a couple people that
disagreed
too much attention she can get her
letter be a child but you know it's
everybod oh and says what she's
passionate what she wants to do it so
I'm gonna take it from her people say oh
she's only on the team because of her
dad I don't score a point for her I
don't pass the ball for her I don't
dribble for her
I don't play defense for her so for this
a that's like really funny to me I love
Jayden play ball at like three years old
at the YMCA just her skill levels
amazing
James meas different the most tenure
girl because old tenure girls aren't
doing what she's doing I can't imagine
Jayden playing against girls her age it
would be crazy she always played up or
against boys well playing against boys
it wasn't hard they think that I wasn't
good so they just let me go but after
that they started Dean up on me and I'll
still score her development has came
from always playing with boys
she's probably bored our whole life but
one time she's played with girls and
when she's played high school so once
she played high school she said wait a
minute this is easier than I thought
when I found out I wasn't
a varsity and third grade I was scared
but after that I got I got used to it
isn't it was easy for me after some of
the girls on the team at first they were
just confused like they were expecting a
ten-year-old to play on their team but
she sees the court well she has reins
when she crossed his girl when she made
girls fall that's when we're like wow
she can handle playing on the varsity
team I work hard because I want to be
though that's what I ever play
basketball and I want go to UConn and
then go to WNBA but I want to be a first
girl to go to the NBA I love her words
at the she's one of the hardest-working
people I know out of boys and girls I
think she's gonna be the best you ever
play basketball she works so hard and it
just didn't happen like she worked for
what she has she was born to play
basketball you know I'm the lighter on
her that I am Julian but I'm lighter on
her cuz maybe she has she is daddy's
little girl so I don't push her as hard
as I push Jill but when I don't she's
the one that comes to me how come you
don't have me do this but you have Julia
do this so she's like that always asking
me to do more so she has a tremendous
work ethic that's only built from within
and that's when things Aidan has
something you cannot teach on a Sunday
we want to me and my husband want to
relax they want to go to the gym it's
like wow we get a break but no it's the
passion and love for that game the work
that we'll take to get there is
everything because you got to work hard
if you want to be the best and if you
wanna be the first girl to go to the NBA
that's a work really hard I don't think
there's been a thought but her mind
she's going and I believe it she could
be the first why not she always tells me
and others that she'll be the first
woman in the NBA and I think it's a not
a goal you hear every little girls say
but I feel like it can happen for Jaden
to make the NBA dream a reality she has
to one not lose focus to continue to
work harder even harder than what she
has been 3 continue to believe we know
what's going to happen by somebody for
why not Jaden I don't feel pressure
because I want it and I know that it
will come true